How does a computer, yeah, make art.
The great artists of our time have
all had their own distinct style.
The Vinci could evoke wonder and
layer hidden messages. In his words,
Goya was able to create an
unmatched sense of dread.
They'll leave blurred the line
between reality and dreams.
The loan artists given the right
medium is able to create beauty.
When the film camera was first invented,
it wasn't thought of as an artistic tool,
just one able to capture reality,
but when artists got their hands on it,
it was the birth of a new era. In fact,
every time we've created a technology,
artists have found a way to
use it as a creative tool,
whether it was meant to track our
hands or just to take hulks. Recently,
advances in machine learning have allowed
us to generate amazing art pieces with
a few lines of code.
What if you could prototype in
a piece a hundred times faster?
Having your medium actually
collaborate with you?
If we can extend these biologically
learned patterns with machine learning
patterns, it'll become much more clear
that it's not that machines are artistic
competitors. It's that we've upgraded
our own creativity. Hello world,
it's Saroj and let's write a python script
to transform any image into the style
of an artist that we choose.
One of the first attempts at computational
artistry with by a British artist
named Harold Cohen in
1973 inspired by his wife,
the prominent Japanese poet Hiromi Ito.
He created a program called Aaron,
which created abstract drawings,
Coen hand coded based structures into it
that we're used to arrive at a four it
was a tree like structure
and using heuristics.
The program was able to take encoded rules
and generate new combinations of what
it knew incredibly.
The paintings that generated ended up
being displayed at museums across the
world from London's Tate
modern to San Francisco. Soma.
Fast forward to 2015 when Google released
deep dream. The Internet went crazy.
All Glory to hip, no toad. They trained
a convolutional net to classify images,
then use an optimization technique to
enhance patterns in the input image rather
than its own weights based on what
he had learned. Soon afterwards,
three German researchers use a CNN to
transfer the style of a given painting to
any image.
They later created a website
called [inaudible] that
lets anyone do this easily.
Since that initial paper,
the Ai community has started to think
about the possibilities for artistry.
You think machine learning,
even Kristen Stewart from twilight publish
a paper on artistic style transfer as
part of her new movie come
swim. Yeah. Also I'm aware wolf,
so let's understand how this
style transfer process works.
By writing our own script and
carrots with a tensorflow backend,
we're going to use a base image,
which is this extremely attractive
photo of me and a style reference image.
Our script, we'll take the style of this
image and apply it to the base image,
so we're going to feed these images into
a neural net by first converting them
into the de facto data format
for all neural nets. Tensors.
The variable function
from Ross is backend.
Tensorflow is equivalent
to TF dot variable.
The perimeter will be the
image converted an array.
Then we'll do the same for the style
image and we'll create a combination image
where we can later store our end result.
We'll use a placeholder to initialize
it with a given with an height.
Let's see if we successfully loaded
our images. Yup. This checks out.
Now we'll want to combine these three
images into a single tensor that we can
feed into our model.
We'll use the concatenate function
to do this in just one line.
The next step will be to download our
pretrained model called BGG 16 that chaos
has wrapped for us beautifully setting
our input to our newly created tenser and
the weights to the image net weights
we'll set include top to false since we
don't want to include the fully connected
layer at the top of the network.
Dgg 16 is a 16 layer convolutional net
created by the visual geometry group at
Oxford that won the image net competition
in 2014 the idea here is that a
convolutional net pretrained for image
classification on thousands of different
images already knows how to encode
the information contained in an image.
It's Lauren filters at each layer that
can detect certain generalized features.
We're going to use these filters to
help us perform style transfer and the
reason we don't need the convolutional
blog at the top is because it's fully
connected.
Layers and softmax function help classify
images by squashing the dimensionality
feature map and how putting a
probability we're not going to classify.
Just transform our input.
We'll frame this style transfer task as
an optimization problem where we have
some loss function that measures an
error value that we want to minimize.
Our loss function in this case
can be decomposed into two parts.
Content loss and style loss.
We'll initialize a total loss is zero
and add each of them to it. First,
the content loss,
we can think of an image as having both
a style component and a content one.
We know that the features that a
CNN learns are arranged in order of
progressively more abstract compositions.
Since the higher level features are more
extract detecting things like faces and
the meaning of the universe
actually not that abstract,
we can associate them with content.
They detect the objects
that make up an image.
When we run our output image and our
reference image through the network
respectively,
we'll get a set of feature representations
for both from a hidden layer that we
choose and we'll measure the Euclidean
distance between them to calculate our
law named after the ancient Greek
mathematician Euclid Alexandria.
The idea of distance is very
useful in machine learning.
We can use it to find rankings,
recommendations, similarities.
It's a mathematical way of comparing data.
The second loss will
calculate his style loss.
This is still a function of our
networks hidden layer outputs,
but it's slightly more complex.
Let's do this.
We still pass both images through
the net to observe their activations,
but instead of comparing the raw
activations directly, like for content,
we'll add an extra step to measure
the correlation of the activations.
For both of our images,
we'll take what's called the grand matrix
of the activations hadn't given layer
in the network. This will measure which
features tend to activate together.
This is calculated by taking the inner
product of all the activations added
given layer, which are a bunch
of vectors. One for each feature.
So this resulting matrix contains the
correlations between every pair of feature
maps at a given layer.
It represents the tendency of features
to co occur in different parts of the
image.
Once we have this,
we can define their style loss as the
Euclidean distance between the gram
matrices for the reference image and
output image and will compute the total
style loss as a weighted sum of the
style loss at each layer we choose.
It turns out that for style,
using just a single layer like we did for
content loss doesn't get great results,
but when using several layers
results improve.
But it's good content and style from
Susan.
Now that we have our losses,
we need to define gradients of the
output image with respect to the loss and
then use those gradients to iteratively
improve our output image to minimize a
loss.
So we'll calculate the derivative of our
loss with respect to the activations in
a given layer to get our gradients and
use them to update our output image,
not our weight,
like we usually would.
Gradients give us a direction on how to
update our output image such that the
difference between the base image
and the style image becomes smaller.
We can call our help classes
combination lost function,
giving it the model and the
output image as perimeters,
so we'll combine the
loss functions into one.
Then get the gradient of the output
image with regard to the loss using the
gradients function of chaos,
which translates to TF dot
gradients under the hood.
This gives the symbolic radiant of one
tensor with respect to one or more other
tensors.
Next we'll run our optimization algorithm
called El bfgs over the pixels of our
output image to minimize this loss,
which is very similar to this,
the Cassick gradient descent,
but quicker to converge.
We'll feed our minimizer function,
the gradients we calculated and
it will output the result image.
Let's see what this looks like.
Dope. I'm going to submit this to Gq.
There are mobile apps
that do this as well.
Prisma lets you pick filters on
your mobile device and our tea.
Stowe even lets you
apply filters to video.
We're still in the early stages of
using machine learning to create art.
So there's a lot of opportunity in
this space. So to break it down,
convolutional neural nets allow us to
transfer the style of any given image on
to another. To do this will compute
loss functions for style and content.
Using outputs from hidden layers we choose
and we can minimize our loss using an
optimization scheme similar to the cast
gradient descent called El bfgs and of
the coding challenge from last
week, is it tied? Of course key.
Can you several features to model Google
stock data and artfully used rms prop
as his optimization technique wizard of
the week and the runner up is Andreas
wine.
Zach loved your plot.
The coding challenge for this video is
to apply style transfer that combines a
base image with two
different style images.
Poster gave a blink in the comments and
I'll announce the winner. Next video,
please subscribe for more videos like
this, check out this related video.
And for now I've got to minimize
my losses. So thanks for watching.